un geste banal de la vie quotidienne
mais après 13 ans de détention ouvrir
une fenêtre n'est pas si simple
après cette première apparition devant
les caméras le 7 mai dernier
omar khadr a accepté de partager ces
premiers jours de liberté avec une
équipe de documentaires le canadien de
28 ans offre pour la première fois sa
version des événements qui ont mené à sa
capture en afghanistan en 2002 à
commencer par l'intense combat du 27
juillet durant lequel est mort un soldat
américain
gravement blessé et capturé par les
américains
les souvenirs du jeune khadr sur cette
période demeure vague hausse en dedans
depuis incapable de dire si c'est bien
lui qui a lancé la fameuse grenade
il sera détenu en afghanistan puis à
guantanamo les interrogatoires se
succèdent et se transforme rapidement en
séance de torture sac sauveur 1 1
les gens étaient agressées sexuellement
dit il drogué humiliés ont simuler la
noyade qui côtière qui pensent qu
minkowski
ça ni à gauche d'un amour on l'accuse
finalement de meurtre pour avoir lancé
la grenade qui a tué le sergent
américain christopher speer l'onu et
d'ong et micky suau tu étais que
pourrait dire il plaide coupable
convaincu que c'est la seule façon de
régler son cas en échange d'une peine de
huit ans de prison et de la promesse
qu'il pourra demander d'en purger une
bonne partie au canada il sera transféré
ici le 29 septembre 2012
aujourd'hui omar khadr est en liberté
sous caution pendant qu'ils en appel de
sa condamnation il redécouvre un monde
qu'il n'a pas vu depuis l'âge de 15 ans
mais il admet qu'il a encore de la
difficulté à baisser sa garde
lundi jour dit il je finirai peut-être
pas ramper sous mon lit pour pleurer
ici daniel thibault radio canada ottawa
la version française de ce documentaire
omar khadr de l'ombre à la lumière sera
présenté ce samedi à 21h ce récit radio
canada télé et mardi prochain à 20h sur
ici rdi